agora
uma das aspirações mais profundas da
pessoa humana alcançar a sabedoria e
aqueles que nós chamamos sábios há
muitos séculos nos apontar o caminho
para a sabedoria caminho é olhar pra
conhecer se a si mesmo como qualquer
conhecimento
inicia se por perguntas e vou fazer
apenas três perguntas
a primeira segunda e terceira razão é
levar a vários níveis de compreensão
daquilo que é o domínio uma dimensão
relacionada com a natureza está no
domingo conhecimento esta dimensão da
natureza e ciência que atua sobre as
domínio distas como somos feitos como
sons estruturados e como funcionamos de
regras regras bastante rígidas inicia
com a observação do fatos com a proposta
de hipóteses e com a concessão de
teorias teorias estão sempre sujeitas a
força dos fatos se não conseguirem
explicar os fatos
elas caia são falsas
para mim a ciência investigar é como que
entrar na porta pela porta de uma casa
como ter como os quatros com muitos
compartimentos
ao entrar nos escolhemos um dos
compartimentos são rígidos têm paredes
rija as rígidas
isto é estão condicionados de maneira
que quando nós fazemos em investigação
nós colocamos fora muitas variáveis do
modo que é conclusão seja o menos
ambígua possível
a ciência tem regras é ciência tem uma
metodologia própria
só assim eu posso perceber como sou
estruturado e como funciona a 1 é a
dimensão ea dimensão da natureza e é o
âmbito do conhecimento
uma outra pergunta isso esta pergunta
não é necessariamente dada pela
metodologia científica a uma pergunta
que vai parar a lei é de ciência isto é
uma outra ciência portar uma ciência com
outra metodologia é aquilo a que
chamamos filosofia o âmbito deste nível
é o âmbito da consciência de si não pode
ser revelada para a ciência pode ser
vista de uma outra maneira com uma outra
metodologia a metodologia da filosofia
hoje eu comparava a olhar por uma janela
é vez de entrar pela porta e ficar no
quarto limitado olhar por uma janela
para a paisagem para a realidade
e reflectir sobre a realidade
telê toda a mão mas não tocar nela
integrar ea partir daí conceber por
falas mais de concessões filosóficas do
pt teorias filosóficas
fala-se mais de teorias científicas do
concessão científica é uma outra
abordagem não é uma abordagem menos
rígida porque é filosofia é conhecida
pela lógica dos argumentos neste um ano
no âmbito da consciência de si
a terceira pergunta por que razão sou aí
nem a ciência com a sua metodologia
rígida nem a filosofia com a sua
metodologia mais aberta podem dar uma
resposta à ciência porque trabalha com o
passado
os fatos são a base da ciência ea
palavra fato vendo ela tem fato novo foi
feito foi feito
é ciência o projeto para o futuro são
probabilidade certeza de maneira que o
futuro que é a resposta do porquê isso
não pode ser
está no âmbito da ciência nem no âmbito
da filosofia porque sendo futuro o
ultrapassa nos na nossa consciência do
nosso mesmo
só pode ser uma outra realidade a
realidade da fé
estamos então
menção a terceira dimensão da pessoa
humana a dimensão espiritual dimensão
física do conhecimento dimensão do
conhecer do da consciência de si e
dimensão espiritual
então é a dimensão da fé não pode ser
dada nem vallée ciência nem para e
filosofia
o que é então a fé a fé é a aceitação de
uma proposta sem evidência científica
para aqueles que crê é fé é algo é que
só responde é previsão do fim e quando
chegamos ao fim o que acontece
estamos a ver que nem ciência e
filosofia diz não se houver uma proposta
no meu caso com extrato de uma partilha
de experiência
no meu caso como cristão a uma proposta
de ferro o que acontece
depois há uma outra dívida e é partir
daqui sem é o símbolo o apoio de certeza
de qualquer sorte
tiramos confiantes nos braços de quem
nos propõe nos faz essa proposta
por isso é que a fé serão lançar-se no
desconhecido sem a proteção do
conhecimento
a fé a fé é em duas dimensões uma
dimensão é inquilina pessoal
aquilo que eu creio em pé é a resposta
que do mês é transvazar da fé para a
comunidade nós somos seja vivemos em
comunidade é esse transvazar do cepr a
comunidade
nós chamamos religião e esta região e
esta fé e esta religião quando elas são
como casas numa ti menção de ação
limitações do ser humano para eu
perceber melhor a mim é minha fé
eu tenho que humanizá la para eu
perceber melhor a minha religião e tenho
que antropomorfizar aula isto é
colocá-la em categorias com que possa
mexer
daí a dificuldade que há em manter limpa
dura esta é aceitação de uma proposta do
futuro com claro a fé ea vivência de fé
a este paradigma da pérola e da cebola o
que é uma pedra uma pérola alma
concreção um produto de um busto de uma
ustra resultante de introduzir
intromissão de um curto estranho na
carne da própria costa
ela vai cobrindo esta é objeto que ele
entrou vai cobrindo com camadas de nácar
da que na cara de que é formar a concha
essas camadas concêntricas vão isolando
o intruso é uma reação alérgica
pérola fica linda
neste o cérebro está morto
mexi a outra visão do brasil e fé a fé
por a cimianto mas rola a não tenham
aparência mexe a maneira como é formada
é semelhante
são camadas sobre camadas que vão
produzindo um núcleo mas com uma
diferença brutal é que este núcleo está
vivo e é este núcleo que dá força às
camadas exteriores do modo a que elas
não só protejam núcleo nós sejam fontes
visita é o paradigma de perna e da
cebola vendo olhando para nós o que é
que eu tenho que ver com estas três
perguntas
tenho que ver porque em mim em cada um
de nós existem os três me fez as três
dimensões
concomitantemente ao mesmo tempo por
isso é a resposta que eu lhes deve
será uma resposta tão completa quanto eu
decidir investir em cada um destes
níveis como indivíduo e como comunidade
porque ao longo da minha vida eu fui
amadurecendo aquilo que chama fé camada
sobre camada vai aparecendo ao longo dos
anos
se for uma camada para evitar que a
queda ser intruso que é fé no projudi
que terei uma pedreira ter uma pérola
linda mas morta por dentro se camada por
camada na minha vida
furo resultante de força interior das
células pluripotentes que são capazes de
dar muito então é minha fé mesmo
era um pouco mal mesmo que tenha uma
aparência pouco convidativa será como a
cebola mas poderá evoluir porque o
centro tenha vida e é assim que eu posso
responder aos três níveis
eu posso vestir a minha vata de
cientista e perguntar na investigar a
natureza e perguntar o sul ou então
envergar as vestes acadêmicas penetrar
no âmago de mim mesmo e perguntar no
tenso com desistido da nino deixe chegar
e perguntar por que razão sou obrigado